also dass die gender gerechte sprache im
mainstream angekommen ist ist für mich
eher ein hinweis darauf dass ein
paradigmenwechsel den letzten
jahrzehnten stattgefunden hatten ich
sehr begrüße
eine sprache die sich ausschließlich der
männlichen form bedient produziert
meiner ansicht nach in permanenz
ausschlüsse nicht genehme menschen intel
geschlechtliche menschen sender einen
der sender die alten post ziehen
jan o erzähler more love herum roubini
sie alle sind für die verwendung einer
gender gerechten sprache jerome rubine
ist schriftsteller und spoken word ist
er ist in frankreich als frau
aufgewachsen in berlin lebt er seit
knapp zehn jahren als mann
2009 10 hat er darüber ein buch
geschrieben der künstler versteht
sprache als ein werkzeug mit dem
gesellschaftliche realitäten abgebildet
werden müssen
jede person hat die freie wahl welche
form der dyna gleichen sprache sie eher
in die tat umsetzen möchte ich denke das
ist zum einen auch notwendig wenn man
bedenkt dass das der staat ein gesetz
verabschiedet hat dass eine dritte
option vorsieht sprich jetzt ganz
offiziell können menschen neben frauen
und männern auch sich als divers
eintragen lassen
wir haben jetzt die dritte option wie
wollen wir das ganz offiziell auch
sprachlich umsetzen
das gender sternchen ist für ihn eine
möglichkeit doch die lösung aller
probleme ist es nicht das weiß auch jan
o er ist chefredakteur der queeren
zeitschrift siegessäule in berlin seit
über 30 jahren erscheint sie monatlich
erst als schwule stadtzeitung dann als
schwul lesbisches magazin
seit 2005 steht quer auf dem deckblatt
der mann schon quer auf dem cover stehen
hat er wird man natürlich sehr genau
beobachtet also das heißt wenn die
siegessäule sich ein fehler erlaubt dann
flippen die leute halt ganz anders aus
als wenn sich jetzt von mir aus die
berliner zeitungen fehler aufweise
irgendwas falsch gesehen hat hat das
sternchen ist in der siegessäule
selbstverständlich komplizierter wird es
wenn der text einzelne personen
porträtiert die sich keinem geschlecht
zugehörig fühlen
denn für diesen fall gibt es bisher im
deutschen keine drohung wenn wir
sozusagen über nichtlineare personen
schreiben dann
haben wir da noch kein wirkliches system
gefunden was den text trotzdem
geschmeidig lässt dann ist es halt so
dann ist der text eben irgendwie
eigentlich eine stilistische
trümmerwüste aber wir wollen nicht um
einen gut lesbaren text zu haben einfach
die identität der entsprechenden
personen die es geht über gehen für
solche menschen möchte lang hornscheidt
die endung und das pronomen enz
etablieren
eins ist der mittelteil von mensch ns
hornscheidt ist in der
sprachwissenschaft und den gender
studies tätig in einem aktuellen buch
erklärt die idee
ich finde es sehr schön wenn es eine
neutrale formen gibt wie wir menschen
bezeichnen da können wir einfach neue
sachen ausprobieren und sprache wieder
aneignen zu sehen sprache etwas
kreatives sprache ist dazu da dass wir
neue formen finden uns auszudrücken lang
hornscheidt geht es darum menschen eine
option zu eröffnen hornscheidt selbst
versteht sich weder als mann noch als
frau
der akademische titel lautet deshalb pro
facts das ixs am ende betont horn schals
ablehnung von geschlechtlicher zuordnung
pc l'amour love nennt sich selbst polit
und die promovierte
geschlechterforscherin ist für das
ständern warnt jedoch vor scheinheiligen
aktivismus von menschen die sich in der
diskussion moralisch über andere schnell
jemand der an unterstrich benutzt ist
kein besserer mensch als jemand der das
generische maskulinum benutzt jemand der
ein unterstrich benutzt kann auch der
letzte diskriminierende typ sein weil
sie damit kann man sich ja auch
schmücken wir sein ist gerade auch sehr
happy sagte sie das sei eigentlich
positiv doch genau darin sieht sie auch
eine gefahr solange es mode ist sagen
dann die leute in der öffentlichkeit ich
habe nichts gegen homosexuelle ich habe
nichts gegen trans personen sobald
dieser mode trend aber wieder vorbei ist
dann wird dieses lippenbekenntnis auch
wieder zurückgenommen
und da wäre es für mich eigentlich
sinnvoller zu wollen die leute es
generische maskulinum benutzen aber
dafür eine echte auch psychologisch
bedingte durcharbeitung von dieser
diskriminierung vollführen die für alle
passende geschlechtergerechte sprache
haben auch sie noch nicht gefunden
das sternchen scheint nicht der weisheit
letzter schluss